[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pardonnez-moi si j'arrive un peu en
retard ma maman ne voulait pas que je
sorte ce soir elle me fait toujours
quand je viens vous voir
mon cher amour toute une histoire
des aventures je peux dire j'en ai eu
des tonnes mais celle-ci dure depuis
trois mois et ça m'étonne car l'amour
m'est venu par hasard
quand je suis monté dans sa Jaguar
[Musique]
es
elle a beaucoup insisté pour que je me
fasse percer l'oreille pour qu'elle
puisse m'offrir un Diam's maintenant je
me fêterai tes
pour faire plaisir à ma poupée
pour les vacances elle veut qu'on aille
à Saint-Tropez
[Musique]
non seulement j'ai plus un copain
mais en plus faut que je me fasse les
chiens j'en ai marre de cette nana marre
de cette nana j'étais bien mieux avant
tout le temps
[Musique]
pourvu qu'elle soit pas toutes comme ça
j'ai dit c'est fini maintenant je casse
à peine parti j'avais déjà les flics sur
mes traces elle leur a dit que j'avais
volé
le diable de mon oreille percé
je me suis fait prendre en traversant la
frontière procès jugement trois mois
ferme je suis sorti hier elle
m'attendait dans sa Jaguar
l'amour m'est revenu par hasard
[Musique]